hi gq my name is christy nelly and today
i'm going to dye my husband's hair
[Music]
we're in my home salon in los angeles
and i'm going to teach you how to bleach
tone and do a multi-color design
before we go into the color i'm gonna do
a quick buzz cut
trim and clean them up
so um i'm finished with this buzz cut so
i think i'm ready to go i feel like a
new man
let's get this step one bleach
i'm gonna use gloves a color bowl
a smaller brush i'm going to use bleach
and 40 developer so i'm going to take
the scoop
i'm using the well of launderer bleach
i'm going to take a scoop out
i'm going to put it in and then i'm
going to measure out i would say the
same with the scoop of
developer and then i'm just going to mix
it together
until it's like creamy i like to put a
little bit of vaseline on top of his
ears
so it doesn't like kind of you know get
on his ears and i'm just gonna apply
you know there's no really right or
wrong way of applying i like to start
with the hairline
so you just want to make sure all the
hair is evenly
saturated
you don't want to start lifting over
here and then take longer over here
you want it to be kind of on at the same
time so it's all lifting evenly
but now that i have it all in keep the
gloves on
and i would take a comb and i would just
comb it through
to make sure it's all evenly saturated
so once
i put it on i'll put a cap on
i'm gonna let it sit on for at least 30
minutes to 45 minutes
but at home i would check it every 15
minutes if you have never bleached your
hair before
this is dracula she cuts his hair too by
the way
he does not get groomed by a dog groomer
i'm gonna check it
like this and
it's okay when you're processing if it
tingles a little bit
all right it looks good it's a pale
yellow how i wanted it so now we're
going to rinse
so the next step i would do after this
is toning allowance have more fun baby
sometimes if you mix like purple with
yellow it becomes green
so i like to tone it to more of a
neutral like
whitish or even like maybe like a
silvery
blonde i'm going to take a bowl and i
like to use
the silver ashy color as you can see it
comes out like purple
i haven't said this much just towel dry
as much as possible
and now i'm just going to apply the same
way that i applied this leash
so this is going to take real fast so
you got to get it on
as fast as possible
and then i would do the same thing with
the comb
and i would just brush it through
and now we're gonna wash it because it's
already turned that fast so we gotta
rinse it right now
you're supposed to take the cape off
when we're rinsing the hair
but clearly you didn't so now i'm going
to put a different cape on him
one that's dry step three multi-color
design
i decided that i wanted to do
a blue a green the orange light purple
a turquoise and a coral what i normally
do just to make sure they look good
together
i put them on a white piece of paper to
see that they'll match like you know
like
i don't like to just go in blindly what
i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna blend one to the other into
like a design on the top of his head
it's all about being creative you can do
whatever you want
i'm going to start with the purple the
light purple
so i'm just going to kind of paint a
little thing like this
i don't want there to be any like
defined lines so i'm just gonna like
kind of swish it out so like for like
this color
i could like go into this
i'm going to go into a different side
i'm going to go right here
with the green
okay i'm going to do this orange color
see even
it doesn't even matter if you're getting
a little bit into each other too because
you want to kind of look like it's
melting into each other see how like i'm
gonna mix the pink in the middle
you really gotta saturate the pastel
colors
or else they don't pick up because
they're just so light
you gotta really get them in there
i'm going to go over it with additional
color to make sure his hair is fully
saturated
with the same colors that are already in
and it's like kind of really splurging
the line still
now that he's fully done i'm going to
let this color process i'm going to let
it sit on for 20 minutes
and then rinse it out to see what the
final result is
if i don't like some of the color i'm
going to go back over
with a little bit of a darker color and
just splash it in there
[Music]
now that it sat on for about 15 minutes
i'm gonna rinse it it processed faster
than i thought it was going to be so we
can see what it looks like
i'm going to see where the color is some
of the color didn't take in both
places because it's too light so i'm
going to go over it
see sometimes when you mix the pastels
does it take
now i'm finished so i'm just going to
take five minutes
because it's going to take a little bit
faster since there's already color
underneath
it i'm just gonna let it sit
remember have fun and be creative and do
what feels right for you
bye bye
[Music]